donc bonjour et bienvenue à toutes et à
tous à ce nouveau de dixin de newman je
m'appelle chloé et
je vous invite aujourd'hui à prendre de
la hauteur avec moi donc avec
mathématiques apprendre à s'aimer
réussir grâce à ses imperfections
alors vous voyez le papangue tout
simplement parce que cet après midi je
vous présentais une méthode que
que j'ai appliqué à ma vie qui m'a aidé
à évoluer et j'ai illustré donc cette
cette méthode de la pap anc
alors pourquoi la palombe tout d'abord
parce que pour moi c'est un animal qui
représente vraiment la perfection la
prise de hauteur et l'homme que vous
voyez sur cette photo c'est mon grand
père donc il est décédé en 2010 d'un
cancer au cerveau et c'était vraiment un
homme de valeur un homme bon un homme
juste et il m'a transmis en fait cet
amour de la nature et maintenant chaque
fois que je vois une papangue je pense à
lui et j'espère qu'il est fier de moi
et d'ailleurs ce soir j'espère qu'en
sortant dès que vous verrez une pente
penserait à main donc qu'est ce qu'une
banque alors le papangue c'est une
personnalité qui soient absolus dans le
domaine du possible en ayant anticipé
avec une narration et une mentalité de
gagnant des résultats qui soient
ultérieure et surtout en harmonie avec
son énergie donc tout d'abord qui
suis-je faut savoir que ce soit je ne
porte aucun masque avec vous donc je
suis la même que chez moi le pyjama
l'icône en moins et donc je m'appelle
chloé comme je vous disais je suis une
ya donc je viens de la plaine des cafres
cilaos et je viens entre 2 donc autant
vous dire que le chouchou coule dans mes
veines
donc j'ai 26 25 ans il ya quelques mois
selon les études j'ai enfin quitter
l'adolescence pour le plus grand bonheur
mon père et je suis fiancée à l'homme
merveilleux qui se trouvent dans cette
salle depuis cette année voilà au niveau
professionnel donc je suis ce qu'on peut
appeler une micro influenceurs donc j'ai
une communauté à peu près de 2000
personnes qui me suivent sur les réseaux
sociaux dont facebook instagram
j'ai également un blog sur lequel vous
parle surtout de tourisme et notamment
le fait d'être une yab d'être une femme
et de vouloir se battre pour être une
guerre boss et met en avant la réunion
et je sais également maman de quatre
chats j'ai pas encore d'enfant mais
voilà
donc il faut savoir aussi que au niveau
de ma personnalité je suis quelqu'un de
très créatif
c'est vraiment la qualité qui le définit
je bouillonne d'idées mais je peux être
aussi extrêmement égocentrique et
égoïste donc je m'aime beaucoup
ça doit se voir je pense mais il faut
savoir que dans la vie j'ai été trahi
beaucoup de personnes m'ont déçu et du
coup j'ai dû compenser avec énormément
d'amour propre et je pars du principe
qu'en fait qu'on peut pas donner aux
autres si on n'est pas remplie nous
mêmes donc on commence avec la citation
d'antoine de saint-exupéry qui nous dit
finalement que la perfection est
atteinte pas lorsqu'il n'a plus rien à
ajouter mais lorsqu'il n'a plus rien à
retirer et pourquoi je vous parle de mes
qualités des défauts c'est que
aujourd'hui je m'aime comme ça à 100%
donc comme je suis et je sais qu'en fait
je vais évoluer vers une meilleure
version de moi même mais voilà je
m'accepte entièrement comme je suis et
j'aimerais que ce soir vous reportez
vraiment vous repartez vraiment avec cet
amour propre pour vous même donc on va
commencer avec le premier paie donc la
personnalité
donc j'ai identifié plusieurs syndrome
que je vois chez moi ou dans mon
entourage et le syndrome de tetris donc
je pense que tout le monde connaît le
jeu qui est juste à gauche la fête vous
avez des blogs de différentes couleurs
différentes formes et le but c'est de
les faire rentrer dans des cases pour
faire disparaître les rides
donc pourquoi je vous parle de ça parce
que pour moi l'humain c'est un bloc de
tetris en fait chacun a sa forme à sa
couleur et à son sens dans la vie
et qu'est ce qui se passe c'est que
souvent on a tendance à vouloir se
conformer
donc qu'est ce qui se passe on va
changer son sens on va dire et on va
essayer de rentrer dans les cases et
finalement tout le monde va disparaître
donc moi il faut savoir que j'étais un
petit peu le mouton noir dans ma famille
parce que j'ai une âme d'artiste j'ai
une âme d'entrepreneur et être dans une
famille de professeur des écoles quand
on est comme ça
aïe aïe aïe donc c'est compliqué donc je
me prends encore aujourd'hui un des
petites remarques genre ah mais
redescend sur terre arrête de rêver
voilà tu es pas bill gates l'asthme on
dit et moi je me dis finalement dans la
vie j'ai envie de faire ce qui me plaît
même si je vais rencontrer peut-être
plus de difficulté d'un parcours
classique mais j'ai envie d'y aller j'ai
envie de tester cette grande aventure
qui est la vie qu'ont choisi pour soi
donc maintenant j'aimerais que vous
visualisez en fait comme une pièce de
puzzle plus tôt donc on est d'accord que
chaque pièce d'un puzzle en fait elle
est unique
donc si vous essayez de mettre de force
un morceau là où c'est pas sa place
finalement ça ne va pas rentrer et en
fait la planète pour moi on forme un
ensemble de puzzle comme ça donc chacune
a sa place
chacune est unique et je vous invite
vraiment à travailler ça
qui êtes vous qu'est ce qui vous
différencie fondamentalement de votre
voisin
ensuite on continue avec le premier a
donc pour absolue une personnalité qui
soient absolus donc on rencontre le
syndrome du problème alors je sais pas
vous mais moi je connais énormément de
gens qui se trouvent en fait mille
problèmes à chacune de leurs solutions
et qu'est ce qui se passe souvent quand
on fait ça c'est que on va se freiner à
mettre des actions en place pour évoluer
et ce qui en découle souvent c'est un
manque de confiance en soi en fait un
manque de se dire allez on y va on se
lance peu importe les difficultés qui
arrive on y va et donc moi par exemple
mon grand tournant dans la vie c'était
au lycée donc il ya plus de dix ans
maintenant
en fait j'avais enchaîné des échecs
amoureux et j'étais vraiment au plus mal
donc j'étais en train de pleurer dans
les escaliers est en fait un ami à moi
qui s'appelle laurent que j'embrasse
s'il regarde cette vidéo il est venu me
voir il m'a dit qu'au et qu'est ce qui
t'arrive
je lui ai dit écoute laurent personne ne
m'aime c'est vraiment ce que je pensais
et là contre toute attente il m'a dit je
reviens dans cinq minutes
et c'est dans cinq minutes tu pleures
toujours je t'en colle une donc c'est
assez brutal comme réaction s'attend pas
à 100 s'attend plutôt à du réconfort
mais au final ce jour là il m'a fait
prendre conscience que je pouvais pas
donner
le droit à autrui d'être maître de ma
vie en fait est que si je voulais
l'amour si je voulais le bonheur il
fallait d'abord que ça passe par moi que
je le crée moi même donc ça c'est
vraiment aussi quelque chose qui est
important ne pas attendre le bonheur les
solutions d autres de voilà de vous
créer vous même votre force là dessus
ensuite donc on continue avec le
deuxième pet de possibles et le syndrome
du feu follet donc le fov le feu follet
pardon qu'est ce que c'est
c'est quelque chose qui va s'enflammer
très rapidement mais qui va s'éteindre
tout aussi rapidement donc je sais pas
vous mais moi j'ai rencontré beaucoup ce
phénomène là dans ma vie d'avoir
l'impression de faire plein de choses
mais finalement après à prendre en
compte les premières difficultés et 11
départs n'ont pas finalement c'est
peut-être pas fait pour moi donc on va
abandonner en fait donc c'est ça le
syndrome du feu follet est en fait y'a
pas longtemps j'ai demandé à mon père
quel était son rêve et il m'a répondu
moi mon rêve c'est d'ouvrir une école
privée
donc mon père ça fait 30 ans qu'il est
professeur des écoles il a plus de 50
ans maintenant
il aurait largement les moyens de le
faire en fait et du coup j'ai dit bah
écoute papa on y va allez c'est parti on
le fait est là tout de suite tu me fais
pas non c'est trop tard
et puis j'ai plus l'énergie donc sa
marmaille cette exclu du c'est trop tard
la meseta bannir absolument parce que
peu importe votre âge moi je suis encore
jeune
comment je peux me permettre de dire ça
mais je sais que peu importe l'avancé
dans votre vie il est toujours temps de
prendre un nouveau départ et d'être
vraiment ce que vous êtes à l'intérieur
en fait ça c'est très important
et du coup voilà donc c'est il faut
visualiser en fait votre votre domaine
de possibilités donc c'est sûr qu'on
n'est pas dans game of thrones on est
pas on n'a pas un dragon pour nous aider
dans la vie mais voilà on peut quand
même planer comme une papangue essayé du
mois on continue avec le à 2
anticipation et le syndrome du poisson
rouge alors ça c'est un médecin dans
préféré c'est que en fait vous prenez un
poisson rouge dans un bocal qui tourne
en rond il a l'habitude de son petit
bocal et vous le mettez ce bocal dans
l'océan
qu'est ce qui va se passer le poisson en
fait ça va regarder comme ça l'océan
c'est grand mais finalement il va
continuer à faire des tours dans son
bocal sans savoir qu'il ya un mouvement
de nageoires de d'avoir accès à tout ça
donc l'anticipation c'est la
visualisation c'est visualiser votre
chemin pour arriver à vos objectifs et
si on prend par exemple le l'exemple de
nemo donc je sais pas si vous connaissez
dessin animé mais nemo c'est un petit
poisson clown qui est perdu et vous avez
marin qui est son papa qui va aller le
chercher en fait qui va monter un plan
un peu loufoque avec son ami dori et qui
va vouloir aller récupérer son fils mais
finalement si on garde ce thème du
poisson rouge
et bien c'est ça que vous devez faire
c'est que vous avez votre pourquoi vous
avez votre objectif et vous savez que
peu importe ce qui va se passer
vous allez y arriver peu importe les
obstacles en fait vous allez trouver une
façon d'y arriver et ça sent
l'anticipation c'est compliqué moi par
exemple l'exercice que j'ai fait
récemment j'ai fait j'ai imaginé en fait
mon cv dans dix ans donc je vous invite
à faire ce travail là parce que du coup
j'ai visualisé l'ensemble de mon
parcours pour arriver à ça et je sais
que même si je n'arrive pas à tout faire
bien évidemment mais voilà je me suis
déjà visualiser dans dix ans et je me
dis je vais me je vais tendre vers ce
profil là en fait donc je vous invite à
à le faire bien évidemment on continue
avec la narration donc le n de papangue
et le syndrome du pain perdu donc là
j'étais un peu taquine c'est le syndrome
du perdu mais comme si gourmande
voilà je vous ai mis une petite photo de
pain perdu donc les syndromes du pain
perdu c'est quoi visualisez vous en
faites par exemple sur la route pour
monter à la plaine des caf
il fait super beau vous avez les idées
claires
et là tout d'un coup vous rentrez dans
le plus gros bouillard de votre vie donc
vous voyez plus rien et du coup qu'est
ce qui se passe on arrête de fonctionner
on arrête le brouillard qu'est ce que
c'est ça peut être votre entourage qui
va peut-être vous faire des petites
remarques de temps en temps dans sa
halle est pas fait pour ma fille un
machin sinon ça peut être quoi ça peut
être vous même on est très bons pour
s'auto sa beauté a peut-être que
finalement
bon c'est pas ça que je veux faire je
suis pas assez doué on doit arrêter ça
vraiment le brouillard ça peut être quoi
d'autre ça peut être votre train train
quotidien qui va vous vous déplacez en
fait vous rattraper finalement qu'est-ce
que vous faites au quotidien vous pouvez
avoir des enfants peux avoir votre
activité vous allez tourner là dedans et
procrastiner en fait vous allez jamais
faire ce premier pas de dire allez
j'avance vers mon projet j'avance vers
qui je veux être vraiment donc ça la
narration est très c'est un très bon
outil pour ça parce que par exemple chez
moi j'ai une centaine de carnets à peu
près et en fait j'écris tout ce qui me
passe par la tête pour vous donner une
idée j'ai déjà une quarantaine d'idées
pour la réunion d'idées de projets et du
coup en fait toutes ces idées là sont à
l'intérieur de ma tête et sa forme en
fait un peu un gribouillis d'enfants et
si vous mettez pas soin papier en fait
ça ça va ça va vous embrouiller l'esprit
ce sera vraiment le brouillard et du
coup à partir du moment où vous allez
écrire vous allez vous sentir beaucoup
mieux
moi par exemple il ya trois quatre ans
j'ai rêvé toute une nuit de la création
d'un hôtel en fait de a à z
vraiment c'était un tout de fou et je me
suis réveillé en fait le matin j'ai tout
écrit j'ai tout dessiné et je peux vous
assurer ce soir que peu importe comment
mais je vais construire cet hôtel
d'ailleurs si vous connaissez un terrain
avec trois pieds de letchis fait appel à
moi donc voilà très important d'écrire
un maximum de choses même si vous avez
passé une nouvelle journée vous avez
envie d'écrire un gros mot sur la page
faite le c'est parce que ça vous libère
en fait on continue avec le g2 gagnant
donc la mentalité de gagnant et le
syndrome du vaincu donc ça j'ai encore
du mal avec parce que en fait quand on a
cette mentalité de gagnant qui n'est pas
encore bien aboutie qu est ce qui se
passe on a un projet qui nous prend aux
tripes on va dire et puis finalement à
la première difficulté on va se dire on
va peut-être que je vais abandonner
peut-être que c'est pas fait pour moi et
du coup voilà on va se retrouver un
petit peu un petit peu penaud et on va
abandonner
donc ce qu'on oublie souvent avec le
fait d'être gagnant c'est que le gagnant
il remporte une épreuve
une épreuve qu'est ce que c'est c'est de
la transpiration c'est de la motivation
et c'est pas pour rien qu'il ya le mot
rage dans courage en fait c'est que ça
va pas être facile
vous n'allez pas ça va pas vous
satisfaire à 100 % et ceux qui comme moi
recherche le plaisir immédiat dans un
projet c'est compliqué donc moi il faut
savoir que j'ai voulu créer ma première
entreprise en 2017 et j'ai attendu en
fait des résultats beaucoup trop rapide
donc qu'est ce qui se passe je me suis
pris la réalité en pleine face et je me
suis complètement découragé j'ai
abandonné et avec le recul en fait je me
dis que avec une meilleure vision une
meilleure stratégie bas j'aurais
j'aurais cartonné dans ce projet là en
fait mais j'étais pas prêtes j'étais pas
prête et je n'avais vraiment pas cette
mentalité là de la gagnante
donc on continue donc des résultats
ultérieurs et le syndrome de
l'impatience donc pour un peu rigoler
qui est impatient dans cette salle voilà
j'ai quand même rassuré donc pour moi en
fait c'est presque
c'est presque évident on fait des train
d'être impatient parce qu'en fait quand
on va se lancer dans un projet qui nous
tient que on va vouloir voir des
résultats immédiats et avoir un petit
peu la carotte avant avant de travailler
quoi
mais dans la vie ça se passe pas comme
ça et comme exemple ce que j'ai à vous
donner c'est que en 2012 donc quand j'ai
rencontré benoît on était en couple tous
les deux mais il s'est passé quand même
une alchimie entre nous donc à l'époque
j'ai quitté mon compagnon pour mon
compagnon pour être avec lui donc lui
aussi sait ce qu'il a fait mais moi il
se trouve que voilà il est retourné sur
sa décision après je me suis pris un
vent magistral voilà en plus on m'avait
jamais dis donc ça blesse voilà mais au
final voilà regardez-nous là huit ans
plus tard on s'est retrouvés et on est
prêt à se dire oui pour la vie
donc derrière cette histoire là qu'est
ce que je veux dire c'est que les bonnes
choses ça prend du temps
et si vraiment quelque chose est fait
pour vous ça finira par arriver
donc il faut que vous mettez une bonne
stratégie en place et que vous preniez
pas la tête avec même si là demain c'est
pas fait pour vous
et peut-être dans quelques années ça
arrivera n'abandonnez pas et on termine
avec le e pour énergie alors sa
marmaille c'est vraiment un des points
les plus importants l'énergie l'énergie
c'est quoi l'énergie c'est votre aura en
fait qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que
constitue votre or à l'intérieur de vous
qu'est ce que votre corps physique peut
vous dire qu'est ce que votre âme qu
est-ce que votre conscience va vous dire
et il faut savoir que l'énergie elle ne
ment jamais donc en général quand ça va
pas dans notre vie on est très bien pour
ans croyez moi mais qu'est ce qui se
passe souvent on va se dire ah non voilà
c'est passage bon j'y vais quand même
erreur erreur alors ma mère elle a fait
un burn out depuis à peu près 7 ans et
elle en est toujours pas ressorti
donc qu'est-ce qui s'est passé en fait
elle était directrice d'école maternelle
et elle a tout donné dans son travail
pendant une quinzaine d'années et elle
n'a absolument pas écouté son énergie en
fait son énergie qui lui disait arrête
tu as des choses à régler avant de
tomber ce tir à ce point dans ton
travail
son énergie qui lui disait stop je te
donne trop à fond il faut que tu prennes
du temps pour toi et au final elle a pas
écoutés et voilà ce qui s'est passé donc
si vous en êtes pas encore là et que
vous sentez que votre énergie finalement
est en train de vous lâcher que vous
êtes vraiment dans dans une mauvaise une
mauvaise passe prenez le temps
d'accepter ça en fait est de vous dire
derrière la tempête il ya toujours le
soleil qui se cache donc inutile de de
commentaires de garder ça pour vous et
vous dire que tout va bien alors que
c'est pas vrai donc il faut absolument
écouter son énergie pour pour faire tout
ce processus là de de développement
personnel on va dire parce que ce sens
né et y arriver de la bonne façon
donc si je devais terminer avec une
autre citation ce serait
la citation d'un groupe coréen de k-pop
que j'affectionne beaucoup dans une
chanson intitulée love my self qui nous
dit que mes cicatrices formé par la vie
sont devenus mes propres constellation
méditons sur la beauté de cette phrase
là qui nous dit que finalement peu
importe ce qui se passe dans notre vie
les épreuves qu'on a eu
elles ont fait de nous ce qu'on est
aujourd'hui en fait et il faut limite
remercier ce remercier revient c'est
notre parcours et si je devais revenir
sur la réunion pour moi la réunion très
importante et chacun chacune d'entre
nous ont fait partie de cette île de
cette magnifique île et je crois que le
monde a besoin de nous les amis le monde
a besoin de nous plus que jamais et
j'aimerais ce soir que vous ne serait ce
qu'une ou deux personnes dans la salle
ça me suffirait mais que vous allumez
cette petite lumière en vous et que on
se lève ensemble demain pour mettre en
avant la réunion et montrer au monde
entier qu'ils nous sommes en fait qui
est la réunion parce que pour moi on est
un exemple international et je pense que
le monde a besoin de cet exemple la plus
plus que jamais donc le mot de la fin ce
serait de vous dire que peu importe ce
qui se passe dans votre vie n'oubliez
pas qu'à tout moment vous pouvez
déployer vos ailes
merci
[Applaudissements]